you ready yes sir
[Music]
it will kill
Daya my name is Neil kamimura I'm 36 and
I'm from Kailua Kona Hawaii
bladesmithing is part of my Heritage my
great grandpa was a blacksmith and eight
months ago when watching Fortune fire
with my son he asked me why I didn't do
it and the moment that I forged my first
blade was the moment I knew that that's
what I'll be doing for the rest of my
life developed into Italy during the
Renaissance the Cinque DEA gained
popularity among civilian noblemen this
large double-edged sword delivered
lethal Cuts in Close Quarter attacks and
was worn on the hip to be swiftly drawn
in times of threatening encounters
derived from the Italian word for the
number five the name chinguadea
represents the blade measuring five
fingers wide at the base which became an
excellent canvas for intricate artwork
with functionality in mind swordsmiths
also included Fullers to lighten the
weight of this otherwise heavy sword
although the chingwood Daya lost its
popularity after the 16th century it has
recently made a comeback in the video
game Assassin's Creed
the moro Chris
my name is Mace Vitale I run a
blacksmithing program at a local Arts
Center I'm also a stay-at-home dad the
Chris came into existence around 1361
A.D in the Kingdom of majapahit East
Java believed to be the primary weapons
wielded by Asian Warriors its
distinctive wavy blade creates a wider
wound during combat causing the victim
to quickly bleed to death the hilt is
viewed as a work of art and is often
carved in meticulous detail from
precious wood gold or Ivory in popular
culture the Chris can be seen in the
video game Mortal Kombat
this is going to be the most challenging
thing I've made so far I don't even know
how to pronounce it
I'm using leaf spring that I got at a
junkyard I find there's a beauty in
taking something that somebody would
throw away and making into something
they keep forever so I'm trying to
incorporate the rest of this metal into
an integral guard by bending these
pieces down I literally do everything
but I I rarely measure anything
you know so it's not going to be this
perfectly symmetrical piece but it's
going to have the hand felt look they
didn't do it back then on some machine
they were doing it by hand this acute
swell is not comfortable in your hand
it's like the opposite got the shape
outlined I got the Fuller started I'm
excited to do this
I'm about to hit a heat treat I couldn't
wait to do it all day and now that it's
time I'm scared because it could fail
worst case scenario my blade could warp
it could crack and then I would have to
start all over again
no warps no bends it was straight
file tested in
it's hard so I'm happy this is still a
competition it's not like the stress is
off anything could happen at any given
time just kind of messing with the guard
a little bit to try and make it a little
bit more fancy
I'm feeling the pressure because David
Baker and Jay Nielsen and Doug are going
to look at it extremely closely and it's
pretty nerve-wracking but at the end of
the day I feel confident that my blade
is strong
and I would take it to battle what do
you think you think you could win
I hope so
I plan on constructing a 23 layer Billet
of Damascus to make the sword from
seven layers for each of my competitors
and later for my daughter I'm there for
my wife my plan is to go to my other
shop and get it heat treated
quenching seemed to go good I didn't
hear any Tings so hopefully we got a
good viable blade throughout my work
I've been trying to harness the spirit
of the tiger and put that in my sword
pointy Blade's gonna have some stripes
the handle is going to have some Stripes
Tiger Claws a little tiger tooth
I'm gonna win
tigers are winners and I am the tiger
the Cinco Deo was used for civilian
dress but it served one purpose to kill
I will take your weapon and deliver
killing blows to this big carcass
all right Neil you ready ready let's do
this
[Music]
okay he goes this is heavier compared to
Dan's blade but the edges are sharp
enough to lacerate the spine all the way
through the base and the weight allows
for a power slash overall the Cinque DEA
will kill
good job
tessell lethality if you're Chris I will
take your weapon I'm going to strike
into this animal carcass May syrup you
ready yes sir
well it cut cleanly through the spine
all the way through the meat in one big
sweeping slash it will kill
good job thank you very much
up next is the sharpness test we will
test both of the edges of your Blades by
delivering a strike across these ratchet
straps Neil your turn you ready ready
let's do this
the dimensions of your handle really fit
my hand anywhere I go it stays right
where it has to be your Edge easily cut
through these ratchets on both sides
your blade will cut
good job right on to test your Chris's
ability to perform according to its
ancient design I will use it to chop and
slice against these moving targets mace
you ready sure
nice
nice balance nice recovery allows you to
just move with a blade
good job thank you
gentlemen to test the strength of your
weapon I'm going to chop into this ice
block four times with each edge of your
sword so Neil your turn you ready ready
[Music]
now the other side
this is heavy
you see the Chingo days with the
multiple Fullers and the purpose of that
is to take that mass out of it it's not
balanced badly because you've got really
thick Tang on there
I see no damage I can't feel
any rolling so it held up beautifully
nicely done thank you bamboo is a very
durable material
ounce four ounce it is stronger than
concrete brick or wood to test the
strength of your crisp I will deliver
four strikes into the bamboo to see how
well your weapon stands up may sear up
welp no damage to the blade sir it
chopped nicely but a couple of times
over there it did want to fall out of my
hand just because it's so heavy on the
blade but nonetheless looks like your
Edge did hold up excellent two blades
One champion you decide the winner
forged in fire war of weapons